foreign
off today's show with several updates on
high profile shooting cases and
specifically the charges connected to
the shooter's parents start off in
Newport News Virginia the mother of a
six-year-old boy is being held
responsible after her son shot his
teacher during class in January the boy
who has an acute learning disability
apparently got the gun from their family
home he brought it to richneck
elementary school in his backpack and
several School administrators say they
unsuccessfully brought it to the
attention of Supervisors now the first
grader shot teacher Abigail zwerner in
the hand and chest in an attack that
authorities say was not an accident
zwerner is recovering but hasn't
returned to work the boy's mother Deja
Taylor is charged with felony child
neglect and misdemeanor recklessness for
leaving a loaded firearm where a child
could access it now we go to Illinois
the father of Robert crimo III is being
charged alongside his son after a Fourth
of July mass shooting last summer seven
people died when cremo III opened fire
on an Independence Day Parade in
Highland Park authorities later caught
the 21 year old shooter after an
eight-hour Manhunt he's charged with 21
counts of first-degree murder 48 counts
of attempted murder and 48 counts of
aggravated battery the shooter's Father
Robert Kramer Jr appeared in court last
week for a case management hearing he is
pleading not guilty to seven counts of
Reckless conduct after prosecutors say
creamer Jr helped his son get a gun
license three years before the shooting
despite his son previously making
violent thrusts threats each count
against cremo Jr carries a maximum
three-year prison sentence and last but
not least we're heading to Oxford
Michigan where the parents have
confessed high school shooter Ethan
crumbly will be headed to trial with
their own set of charges now you might
recall that in November of 2021 four
students died and six other people were
injured when crumbly who was just 15
years old at the time opened fire inside
Oxford High School last October crew
crumbly pleaded guilty to a 24 count
indictment that included first degree
murder and terrorism charges his parents
though have pleaded not guilty to
involuntary manslaughter charges
prosecutors accused them of neglecting
to address their son's mental health
issues and instead buying him a gun that
gun was eventually used in the mass
shooting a judge ruled last week that
crumley's parents will not be allowed to
attend their son's latest hearing that
hearing set for May 1st will determine
if crumbly will be eligible for parole
or will have to spend the rest of his
life in prison let's break this down
Terry were the charges against Deja
Taylor in in Virginia sufficient or
maybe there should have been more
serious charges what do you think well I
think these were pretty serious charges
that felony charge it does carry a
five-year sentence if in fact she is
convicted of that it's really Reckless
what she did and the misdemeanor charge
for having that loaded gun and
endangering the child that's another
year so the neglect and the gun charge
those can add up to some pretty
significant charges there and some
significant time but also the
authorities did say they're continuing
to investigate this so there could be
additional charges and if they find that
the mother knew what was happening or
she should have suspected it because he
might have some issues that she's seen
in the past they could up those charges
maybe to even involuntary manslaughter
see Brian I think the crumbly case
started everything and I'm wondering if
is it if it's encouraging other
prosecutors Across the Nation to go
forward with charges against parents
absolutely Jesse prosecutors have the
discretion to bring charges or not bring
charges and I think a lot of the time
when you look at cases like cases
against police officers cases against
powerful men who sexually assault women
who then report years later now are
getting into a new genre of cases that
being parents held liable for their
children's actions in gun cases I think
prosecutors seeing that the country is
more open and welcome to these charges
and there's a greater likelihood of a
conviction if they do bring these
charges I think the crumbly case is
having an effect on the rest of the
country and we know what the goal is
right the goal is to prevent bees
shooting so we'll see maybe it'll have
some effect Brian Terry thank you both
so much everyone out there thanks for
joining us here on the daily
all right welcome back everybody so
right now we are bringing you an
exclusive long crime interview with a
former Disney star heading to trial
after some pretty serious allegations I
want to bring in my co-host Brian Buck
Brian buckmeyer Brian you had a chance
to sit down with the defendant Kyle
Massey what can you tell us yeah Jesse
Kyle Massey the former That's So Raven
Disney star is being charged with
immoral communication with a minor at
first glance it seems like a simple case
the question being did come Massey send
a minor sexual materials over the phone
or internet but after sitting with
Massey and his attorney this case seems
anything but simple
the fact is they're alleging is that you
knew this young girl from the age of
four and you knew the family and that
there was some sort of communications
that the relationship with you I've seen
them describe you as a father figure
almost to this girl and I love the
reaction because I want to get into that
as well and you were supposed to Marshal
her through the the industry so to speak
I've even heard allegations that you uh
supposedly said that she can come and
live with you from Seattle to LA with
you and your girlfriend and you would
help her in this endeavor of trying to
become famous and that what a month or
two after that invitation that's when
you were on her Snapchat you sent
allegedly some some photos of someone
that looks like you who might have been
nude and and sexual photos those are the
allegations from from my understanding
yeah
I'm gonna try to give it to you first
what is your response to those
allegations uh
my response to those allegations are
that
first off we would need to go back let's
go back to to the mother of this of this
kid right you stated in your in your um
paperwork that I've known this kid
um since she was four years old right
well the the truth about my relationship
with that mother is that that mother had
a inappropriate sexual relationship with
me since I was a kid when I was 15. so
let me let me expound upon with Mr
Massey is saying so there is some
discrepancy on when the date that they
actually met
um the mother in this case is saying
that they met in 2009 Mr Massey alleges
they met in 2007. So based on Mr
Massey's birthday which anybody can
Google that's a 15 16 year old versus a
17 18 year old so um and then that's
where she advances this whole thing
about her daughter he's known her since
she was four now if you look at the
police report where she gave her
statement to the police she said Mr
Massey met her at Universal Studios
California
um Studio City I'm sorry California and
that she was with her children other
adults in a group and that Misty Mr as
he approached her from the group and was
trying to get her phone number now if
that's the case then how would Mr Massey
have known any of the children present
belong to her
or belong to anyone else he's just
seeing you and a group of individuals
and and that's just using what she has
said I'm not saying that this is
necessarily the case but this is her
version of events that she gave to
police so she's using attempting to use
that if you will to try to set out that
he's known a child as if he met the
child directly he never met the child
directly there was no interaction with
the child is the video something that
was meant to be sent to like another
adult yes the video was like right this
could be something that is wrong the
issue but I did it accidentally correct
and the issue is that there's no feed or
conversation leading up to this there's
no oh let me send you something oh why
don't you there was no segue it's
flirting no no flirting no every all the
communication is straight laced when
she's saying oh my God blah blah blah
how you doing it's oh I'm good you know
how was your day
there's no no communication where Mr
Massey is soliciting photos from her or
she's soliciting photos now I can sit
here and I can and I can like look at
you and say it without breaking down but
you gotta understand this was like one
of the hardest moments in my life
um because
the person that
molested raped took advantage of me when
I'm when I was a child is now painting
me as the predator
yeah so we'll continue to follow Kyle
Massey's case out of Kings County
Washington State as he awaits his trial
which is scheduled now for July